[Music]
good afternoon everybody welcome to our
breakout session my name is min Han I'm
a software engineer on the kubernetes
engine networking team so we're here to
talk about container native low
balancing on kubernetes engine we have
three items on the agenda first how
Google cloud treats containers as
first-class load balancer endpoints and
second how kubernetes engine natively
supports advanced level 7
functionalities and finally we have a
surprise session with something coming
soon in 2015 kubernetes 1.0 was launched
google brings its container experience
of over a decade to the industry as an
open source project kubernetes focused
on portability it uses the lowest common
denominator technology that includes low
balancing in 2015 most low balancers
only work with virtual virtual machines
and bare metals they do not support
containers natively low balancing
solutions for kubernetes usually involve
some kind of proxy to pass traffic from
the low bouncer to the container in
summary when kubernetes was born low
balancing solutions was not optimized
imagine you are a customer with
multi-tier application I have my project
on Google cloud at my virtual network in
my project of my kubernetes engine
cluster running in my virtual network I
have my workloads running in the cluster
now how do I expose my services to the
Internet the answer is the community
service abstraction so the kubernetes
service abstractions provides two major
functionalities first it selects a group
of back-end you
using label selectors second it provides
static access point to these back-end
pods on the Left there's a sample
service specification it's name is my
service it selects pods with label key
equals to app and value equals to my app
it exposes port 80 and it's type is
cluster IP for external traffic in
particular there's no port type service
and there is low balancer type service
logically the diagram in the middle
represents how the traffic flows the
traffic first arrives at the service
abstraction represented by the red icon
and then the service will deliver the
traffic to one of the backend pod
represented by the blue icons on top of
service there's an ingress resource in
kubernetes it represents a level seven
low balancer a no port type service
allocates a static port across all
cluster nodes traffic flowing to the no
port on any VM or any node will be
forwarded to one of the back-end pod
this model is very easy to understand
there's no external dependency user just
need to run the standard open source
queue prostitute have this feature the
downsides are obvious there are only
limited number of no port within the
cluster and the clients need to adjust
to node IP changes and no port only
provides basic low balancing algorithm
basically spreading the traffic randomly
all these results into sub optimum load
balancing in kubernetes there's a cloud
provider abstraction layer this layer
makes it easy to integrate kubernetes
api with different infrastructure
this makes kubernetes api portable
across platforms when user creates a low
balancer types are
this a real Loeb answer will be
provisioned it usually comes with the
external virtual IP traffic first flow
to the virtual IP it arrives at the low
bouncer and the low balancer will
deliver the packet to kubernetes service
in most integrations the low bouncer
would just deliver the packet to a no
port type service and the service will
further deliver the packet to the
back-end pods kubernetes services are
level four constructs in order to
support level seven functionalities
ingress was proposed ingress supports
the popular level 7 functionalities like
TLS termination URL path mapping there
are many ingress implementations on
kubernetes engine it utilized google
cloud load balancer to implement the
ingress api conceptually ingress traffic
first arrives at the ingress layer that
can be a Google cloud load balancer then
the level 7 functionality is kicked in
TLS termination and your our path
mapping and the load balancer will
deliver the traffic to the corresponding
service and the service will take it to
the backend pods we have briefly walked
through the kubernetes api constructs
for low balancing
although the api seems straightforward
but the underneath data path can be very
very complex to understand what is
container native load balancing we need
to take a closer look at the data path
here is a typical ingress set up on
kubernetes engine all other cloud
providers have some similar setups when
user creates an ingress kubernetes
engine we'll create a google cloud load
balancer and the google cloud load
balancer will point to an instance group
the instance group contains all cluster
nodes and queue proxy is responsible for
forwarding traffic to the actual
back-end pod
the name of Q proxy is quite misleading
it's not a real proxy it programs
iptables
and asked the Linux kernel to do its job
so this setup results in sub optimum low
balancing as you can see in the
animation the blue dot represents the
incoming traffic load balancer cents
packet to the virtual machine and cube
proxy programs IP tables to intercept
traffic from the low balancer
then the inter in I P tables magic took
place IP tables randomly select one of
the backend pod perform network address
translation port translation and finally
sent the packet to the destination pod
because the back end part selection is
randomized the IP tables can select a
pod on a different node that will result
in a second network hop for the response
packet it will reverse the incoming data
path so the pod will send out a response
packet the packet will first arrive in
the forwarding node on the forwarding no
IP tables and contract table will undo
all the network traffic net were
addressed translation and port
translation and then the packet will
return back to the load balancer so with
all these it's very very complex there's
a lot going on just to deliver packet to
the container now we are proud to
announce container native low balancing
using Network endpoint group feature on
Google Cloud Network endpoint groups
feature allows Google Cloud load
balancer to target containers directly
containers become just another endpoint
as you can see in the animation there's
no IP table magic there's no proxy
involved no need for the complex network
address translation and of course
there's
no second hobb every connection is
established directly between the low
balancer and the back end part so let us
have a side-by-side comparison
the data path becomes much much cleaner
so what difference does it make Network
endpoint group makes low balancing for
containers as efficient and as easy as
low balancing for virtual machines so
let's summarize Network endpoint groups
makes container first class citizen on
Google cloud load balancer he opens the
door for native container support for
many low balancer features such as
traffic shaping advanced low balancing
algorithms and many more
take traffic shaping as an example
without net were n point group load
balancers can only do traffic accounting
per virtual machines with the secondary
low balancing happen on the virtual
machine low balance or loses track
switching traffic between VMs doesn't
result in switching traffic among the
actual back end pod what that were M
point group load balancer gains the
visibility into each traffic flowing to
every containers accurately then traffic
shaping is achievable at the container
level secondly data path is optimized
there's no longer any proxy between the
low balancer and the backend pod that
eliminates the second network hop this
reduces the latency and removes the
overhead for the complex network address
translation and resolves as a
predictable network performance finally
tools that integrated with Google Cloud
balancer gets visibility at the
container level automatically
low balancer health check can retrieve
accurate health status per container
without network endpoint groups
low balancer cents the health check to
the virtual machines and virtual
machines force the health check request
all over the place that makes the health
check result unreliable with all that I
would like to introduce my colleague
module Thank You min Han for making load
balancing boring again min Han just gave
us an overview of how our load balancing
is becoming more container native I will
now touch upon how our network services
are also becoming more container native
Google cloud platform network services
have the mission to deliver services
that are smart secure and modern on the
Google cloud platform and other clouds
we bring these strengths to the your
kubernetes engine deployments via
ingress and a host of other feature
improvements we all know that ingress is
your one-stop-shop for configuring all
your l.7 needs including your global
HTTP google cloud load balancer up until
now you could set your host path routing
rules via ingress to be set up at the
HTTP Google cloud load balancer using
kubernetes Native ingress API we have
been working at kubernetes engine to
bring kubernetes engine networking at
par with compute engine and establishing
containers as first-class endpoints with
these changes you will be able to use
the kubernetes ingress api to configure
l7 security authorization for your
employees and use a globally distributed
caching infrastructure configure
security policies for defense at scale
against distributed denial-of-service
attacks with loud Armour using Google's
global infrastructure and security
systems use cloud armor in your
kubernetes engine deployments to protect
against malicious attacks at the edge
and restrict access to the load balancer
I would recommend going to the session
on cloud armor by projector control
access to your internal applications at
application level granularity using
identity based access control with
identity aware proxy cloud IEP or
identity aware proxy lets you establish
a central authorization there for all
your applications accessed by HTTP so
that you can use an application level
access control instead of the older
network level firewalls which gives you
an all-or-nothing application level
granular access level granularity third
leverage a globally distributed caching
infrastructure for all your low latency
applications using cloud CDN caching
content at the edges of Google's network
infrastructure using our over 90 CDN
locations will provide you faster
delivery of your content to your users
while reducing serving costs together
with the above capabilities you can
build applications on kubernetes engine
that are smart secure and modern we will
demonstrate the integration of these new
capabilities and how ingress on Google
cloud platform becomes the single pane
of configuration for all your l7 needs
let's jump into a little more detail on
how we can do that
so we introduced a new concept called
the backend config but before we do that
let's see let's see let's jump in to a
little more history as you might already
know kubernetes ingress API is the open
source and portable way to express your
l7 configuration since it was meant to
be portable the only way to have
provider specific information was
through ingress annotations
this made the integration of new
features either dependent on the
approval of the community affecting the
speed of overall development or an
overpopulation of annotations on your
ingress definition maintaining this
delicate balance between provider
specific information and an ingress
portability is not an easy question to
answer
so back in config aims to address
exactly that problem we introduced back
in config to specify configuration on a
per service basis use back in config for
your Cloud Google cloud platform network
services like cloud armored identity
aware proxy and cloud CDN to begin with
back in config is a new kubernetes
custom resource that is a kubernetes
native concept and is specific to Google
cloud platform back in config lets you
specify configuration for all your
services without the need of polluting
your ingress definition with too many
annotations as was the case in the past
and which makes your ingress definition
non-portable this simplifies your in
experience with the ingress API there's
native integration with all the GCP
network services giving you a host of
benefits and service configuration
becomes a first-class concept you have
the flexibility to specify configuration
pertaining to a single service rather
than and all or nothing for you or for
your whole deployment you can hook up
your sir
definition using back in config to use
all these network services now let's
move on to some of the new features that
we have for ingress on the Google cloud
platform
Mahon already mentioned that ingress can
be used for TLS termination today we
announce the availability of multiple
TLS or multiple ssl certificate support
through your ingress definition instead
of the older way of bundling multiple
domains into a single certificate or
having multiple ingress definitions that
adds overhead we also try to ensure at
kubernetes engine that your interest
remains competitive in the integration
of new protocols and new technology
ingress now supports HTTP 2 protocol
which is designed to improve performance
over its over its predecessor which is
the HTTP 1 protocol support for HTTP 2
enables you to use G RPC which is an
open source framework for remote
procedure calls based on the HTTP 2
standard G RPC enables you creation of
performant scalable api's and micro
services in many programming languages
and platforms to summarize what we have
mentioned till now we bring you a host
of new capabilities and features to
configure at L 7 via ingress on the
Google cloud platform the concept of
back-end config which lets you set
configuration on a purse service spaces
without the need of polluting your
ingress definition with too many
annotations and gives you flexibility to
specify things on a per service basis
rather than for your whole deployments
native integration with Google cloud
platforms network services which lets
you get a host of benefits including
security at L 7 using cloud armour
identity based access control for your
applications we are identity aware proxy
and a globally distributed caching
infrastructure you
in cloud sealian ingress on the Google
cloud platform also lets you use
multiple SSL certs for your deployment
and use new protocols such as HTTP 2 and
G RPC with that I'll hand over to boy
who is the kubernetes engine TL to show
you a host of new features okay
hello thanks my joke so
kübra is engine makes it easy to create
Google call load balancers and it's full
of features as you have seen in the
previous slides but we've heard lots of
questions about how to extend your
applications using ingress across
multiple clusters whether it's for fault
tolerance or to optimize latency and
what I'm going to show you is a sneak
peak of something that we're currently
working on so suppose you create an app
you deploy it on kubernetes engine in
North America and you have users coming
to your cluster now your app gets very
popular actually popular all over the
world now you have users coming from
London Singapore all over from Europe
Asia but your application is still being
served from a North American cluster
note that the Google cloud load balancer
will terminate your connections at the
Google edge you'll see there's a Google
edge in North America Europe and
Singapore which gives us your users the
benefits of low latency protocol
termination however the application will
see still served from your North America
location so the end-to-end application
latency may be higher for some users in
the world now today you can do localize
your application by using DNS with this
setup you can create an ingress for each
cluster you're serving in the region
that you want it to serve and then have
a different VIP for each and put that
virtual IP in your DNS record well this
gives you geo localization as you know
DNS has subbed off the mul load
balancing and failure over
characteristics in addition you need to
maintain multiple copies of the ingress
resource and synchronize them among your
clusters
also we need to set up geo DNS so we are
sited to announce an upcoming feature in
kubernetes engine which is multi cluster
and multi-regional ingress support with
this feature you will be able to write
one ingress definition and use Google
cloud load balancer distribute traffic
among the clusters from a single anycast
IP now as your user base expands say
worldwide you will be able to add
clusters in each region where you will
have users following your user
population as needed as you see from the
diagram there'll be a single virtual IP
that will be programmed into your DNS
and traffic from each of your clusters
will be routed to the closest one in
fact if capacity is exceeded or of a
cluster goes down your user will be
routed to the next best destination
automatically as failure is detected now
actually let's take a hands-on look at
some of the details about how this will
work so give me one second okay so here
we have a dashboard that is wired up to
a live instance of the multi cluster
multi-regional ingress and as you see
following the workflow from before we
have a North American cluster and most
of our users are from North America so
they experience you know acceptable
latency we have a few users from Asia
but not too many now as we increase the
traffic because our app got super
popular we get a lot of users from Asia
but you'll notice that they're still
hitting the North American cluster with
multi cluster and multi-regional ingress
we can actually add a cluster you see
that we added a cluster in Asia but we
haven't updated the routing now finally
we will update the routing so that this
cluster is included in the load balancer
and as you see the users in Asia will go
to the Asia cluster and the users in
North America will go to the North
America cluster now let's poke a little
bit in terms of what this actually looks
like so
here is the ingress definition for this
setup you notice that it is just the
vanilla kubernetes ingress definition
and in fact when you go and look at your
network service in Google Cloud UI
you'll see that it sets up a single
virtual IP and the difference is you
have two back-end services one of them
in Asia and one of them in North America
finally let's see what happens for your
users right there users we have clients
in Asia and we have clients in North
America so here's an access log that's
been aggregated across the cluster
showing where the user request was
coming from and which cluster is served
and as you can see requests coming from
North America are served by the North
American server and requests coming from
Asia are being served by the Asia
cluster now we're switching back to the
presentation ok so what are the benefits
of multi cluster and multi regional
support so notice you have a single
configuration for your global
applications you will use a single
standard ingress definition that you
already use to define your HP
applications this definition will be
used to configure a global multi cluster
Google cloud load balancer giving you
one place for configuration and status
the multi cluster multi-regional ingress
will use network endpoint groups to
address your cluster endpoints and as
you saw earlier this has all the
advantages of container native load
balancing you have accurate health
checks better load balancing algorithms
in optimal network performance and
finally in the most straightforward
point you have geographical load
balancing and high availability and
using this feature will make your Akoo
brunet ease apps and services globally
distributed so as you saw in this talk
there's a little bit of history about
where container load balancing was and
some indications of what we think the
final form should be and the final forms
should be container native
load-balancing what is container native
load-balancing first and foremost it
means that containers have optimal
network transport load balancers are
container aware there should be no
difference whether your workload uses
containers or VMs it should just work
second your container workloads can use
Google cloud load balancer feature set
for example security caching
authentication in a kubernetes native
way using kubernetes resources and
configuration finally coming soon
kubernetes engine will support extending
load balancing across multiple clusters
and regions giving your applications
global reach and high availability we
want to make it so that any choice of
technology whether it's containers or
VMs runs the best on Google cloud and
container native load balancing is a
piece of that puzzle thank you
[Applause]
[Music]